[Musique]
les jeux nationaux du sport d'entreprise
une huitième édition qui se déroule en
martinique une huitième édition qui a
débuté avant-hier le mercredi 8 mai et
qui s'achèvera demain samedi bon jour
ils vont cibler y
bonjour à tous vous êtes le président de
la ligue martiniquaise du sport
d'entreprise femmes trois disciplines
durant quatre jours se représente
combien d'athlètes pour cette édition ça
représente plus de 2000 athlètes dans ce
moment donc c'est une belle
manifestation
c'est quoi le niveau de ces athlètes se
sont d anciens professionnels ce sont
des amateurs de bon niveau c'est
monsieur tout le monde
il ya un peu de tout il ya des anciens
professionnels qui surtout qu'ils sont
inscrits dans les délégations de
métropole sinon martyrs nous avons un
peu de tours un monsieur madame tout le
monde qui participent à cette re 8e
édition des jeux nationaux du sport
d'entreprise alors la martinique qui a
qu'une telle manifestation on va en
parler c'est la preuve que notre il doit
jouer droit pouvoir jouer fait déjà joué
la carte du tourisme sportif tout à fait
puisque nous avons réalisé la première
édition des jeux nationaux du sport
d'entreprise en 2016 et nous avions 1600
athlètes et dont 400 venus de la
métropole
donc cette année à la deuxième édition
réalisa martinique
nous avons plus de 650 personnes qui
sont venues pour participer à ces
huitièmes jeux nationaux
donc on est tout à fait dans l'optique
dans la vision du sport tourisme en
martinique en ce moment alors sur les
hôtels qui en profitent le plus sur les
restaurants mais ce sont les hôtels ce
sont les restaurants ce sont les lois de
voitures ce sont les marchands pistache
à côté ce sont ceux qui vendent quelques
boissons sucrées pour les athlètes et
voilà ton c'est l'économie de la
martinique
et puis cette période de l'année nous
sommes début du mois de mai c'était la
plus propice pour ce genre de
manifestation mais c'était la première
semaine de
de la basse saison donc on a profité
pour pouvoir faire venir les gens durant
cette période
donc pour les hôtels c'est une aubaine
qu'ils ont pu profiter d'avoir nous
avons complètement pris un hôtel à nous
tous seuls pour le à nous tout seul pour
pouvoir organiser cette manifestation
alors justement de point de vue
logistique
tout se passe bien et nous sommes à la
hauteur mais nous sommes à la hauteur
puisque les jeux ont commencé depuis
hier au lamentin a lancé de mot ni
d'ouverture
ensuite c'est elle et la la la les
compétition au début tu es ça se passe
très bien donc nous avons déjà des beaux
vainqueurs
donc ça roule très bien donc on va
essayer de terminer demain avec une
belle cérémonie
ouais et puis ce sera la cérémonie des
partenaires les partenaires sont
nécessaires et obligatoires pour ce
genre de manifestation qui sont
obligatoire sinon sans eux on ne peut
rien faire justement ce genre de choses
abel et à des partenaires publics des
partenaires privés on va pas tous les
citer ici même en est s'il faut les
sites et si vous avez la permission de
les citer session de formation se
démarque pas trop mais on a vite compris
que les partenaires privés sont l'ap le
mouvement sportif dans son dans cette
globalité peut espérer quoi de jus
nationaux de sport d'entreprise
le mouvement sportif avec nous avons
discuté avec le président dit cette
hausse marque un ami monsieur pierre
michel auger et qui disait que pour lui
c'est le sait je représente un gain une
manière de montrer aux athlètes aux
ligues délégataire on peut s'organiser
on peut s'entraider
parce nous au sein de la ligue de martin
dispose reprise on est ligue multisports
et on s'appuie des ligues délégataire
pour nous aider à organiser les
manifestations nord la ligue de foot
organisme tout ce qu'il faut de la ligue
de tennis qu'est tennis donc on se fait
aider par sceller pour pouvoir mener
cette manifestation a bien il s'agit de
développer la pratique sportive de
trouver de nouveaux licenciés de trouver
de nouveaux licence et surtout poussé
poussé ligue 1 puisque bon quand ils
vont participe au tennis demain matin
pour s'inscrire à la ligue de tennis et
après celui de la voile va c'est ce que
ce sont surtout dans ces athlètes qui
revêtit qui viennent dans le monde de
l'entreprise là ce sont des maîtres
anciens mais qu arrêter maintenant
le but c'est de leur faire reprendre la
compétition parce que vous savez que le
sport au sein même des entreprises à se
poser amène une valeur supplémentaire
oui alors pour les autres pays justement
c'est quoi l'objectif chercher plus de
social plus de sociétés plus d'esprit
d'équipé au sein même de l'entreprise
il s'agit de faire corps ça peut fédérer
également de pratiques mais vous avez
tous déjà il faut fédérer en bon on
fédère il ya un meilleur esprit d'équipé
ont une meilleure cohésion au sein même
de l'entreprise parce que vous savez que
quand enfin on fait du sport le dimanche
ou le samedi avec le patron l'ouvrir le
drh et tout le monde quand on a eu le
lundi matin il ya une crise qui fait ça
il ya des fois on n'a pas envie de faire
du vélo avec son patron oui et non on ne
vit pas de le faire tous les jours mais
ce qu'est ce qu'une fois de temps en
temps ça fait du bien oui mais justement
est ce que chaque entreprise n'a pas eu
sa propre vision des choses est ce que
vous avez discuté par exemple avec
certains chefs d'entreprise qui ont
plusieurs salariés qui disent ballet
sport dans mon entreprise d'accord ça va
me permettre de retrouver cet esprit de
corps ou bien apprendre à mes salariés à
se surpasser
chacun peut y venir et puis vouloir
trouver une chose mais précise vous
savez en métropole ça existe de plus en
plus surtout dans les pays nordiques le
les directeurs les drh ont compris la
chose le fait de donner un cadre une
demi-heure à son employé ça lui permet
de gagner énormément en gains de
productivité productivité donc celui qui
fait du sport avec son patron même le
midi entre midi et deux on met un quart
d'heure le matin avant de commencer
c'est sur le bureau il se sent mieux
dans sa peau il est plus productif il
travaille beaucoup plus pour le patron
donc le patron a tout à gagner à donner
quelques heures quelques même quelques
minutes à son employé pour pouvoir fable
faire du sport
alors là vous me donnez vous me
permettez d'eau poser certaines
questions concernant ce sport
d'entreprise ils vont fib l'oeil ça doit
se faire
où quand comment sur les horaires de
travail ça peut se faire sous les
heureuses de travail et c'est le bon
vouloir du patron c'est le bon boulot du
patron mais vous savez un patron qui
vous donne 15 minutes
j'ai deux trois heures ferrière 15
minutes savez le fait simple fait de se
lever et de faire 15 minutes
d'étirements autour de sa table autour
de son bureau permet de se muer se
sentir et permet aussi de d'être plus
productif de travailler mieux pour la
direction donc je pense que les
directeurs les virages ils ont tout
compris et maintenant ils s'adonnent à
cela et quelles infrastructures alors ce
sont les infrastructures a dû du du
civil
non non il ya deux possibilités soit
vous faites ça au sein même de
l'entreprise avec une petite structure
d'une petite salle je sais pas tout le
monde qu'elle aimerait mètres carrés
mais vous savez on peut pousser 4 4
chaises de bureau et avoir un espace de
12 m² facilement et en 12 mètres carrés
on met facilement une dizaine de
personnes et afin de faire un peu
d'étirements influent de ce riz chine un
feu de relaxation et tout ça ça permet
de mieux travailler après alors soyons à
seront jusqu'au boutiste est ce que si
ce sport d'entreprise se développe ça ne
risque pas de devenir une sorte de
concurrence pour le sport martiniquais
nous sommes quand même amateur faut pas
l'oublier non pas du tout c'est pas
c'est pas la chose et à l'esport un mot
c'est même de l'entreprise via les
sports pour l'entreprise et à l'espace
civil
ça n'a rien à voir il faut faire la part
des choses le fait de faire les sports
même au sein de son entreprise permet
même à la personne de se sentir bien au
sein même de son entreprise
mais après quand je vais faire du sport
après mon boulot tout cela donc c'est un
peu plus personnel
donc voilà on sait c'est pas du tout la
même chose est ce que ça peut être
l'occasion pour les pour pour les
marques de se faire connaître davantage
je vais dire n'importe quoi telle ou
telle entreprise qui fabrique par
exemple des gâteaux à place d'armes au
lamentin qui rencontre ce qui vendre des
livres ou des haies disque quelques
parcours de françois rivière salée c'est
l'occasion de faire peuple de faire
société
entre sportifs entre entreprises le but
c'est cela c'est d'échanger
le dl drh de le nôtre hobbies x compte
le drh d'une entreprise y s'a échanges
l'ouvrier de l'entreprise intel on
compte les ouvriers de l'entreprise
intel ils échangent et le but c'est de
d'échangés le
de trouver une manière de mieux se
sentir en train vers ces différents
échanges à travers ses différents sports
et puis surtout on aurait peut-être dû
commencer par là ils vont film 'le du
bluff faire du sport c'est répondre à
des attentes et aux enjeux santé de la
société d'aujourd'hui stress mal de dos
la sédentarité mais comme je le disais
tout à l'heure un le simple fait de
faire du sport
on se sent mieux dans sa peau on a on
est moins stressé quand on arrive au
travail le matin donc le but c'est de
dédit les salariés d'entreprises avoir
moins mal et des plus productives pour
pouvoir mieux gagner demeure en santé
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nous ils
vont cibler rappelle que vous êtes le
président de la ligue martiniquaise du
sport d'entreprise vous savez ce soir là
à la cérémonie des partenaires et puis
demain les dernières épreuves et puis
dimanche tout le monde rentre à la
maison
merci d'avoir été avec nos bonnes
journées merci